but my question here is why now why is
this developing now because people have
suffered from rare conditions since the
start of human history why is it taking
off at this point exactly so the reason
why it's taking off at this point is
because we're actually able to sequence
people's genomes for a reasonable price
so when the first human genome was
sequenced in the human genome project it
took them three billion dollars and 13
years to do and so that's just not a
price at which it makes sense now the
cost of sequencing genes is falling and
now it's starting to get towards $1,000
per person and so that means you can
start sequencing large numbers of people
and start to look across large databases
to see if there are trends if there are
patterns that tell you you know what
genes are related to what symptoms are
what conditions and also to look for
outliers people who are extremes and
have really strange mutations what's the
most valuable part of this process is
that the database of people with these
rare genetic mutations yeah so having
large databases is truly valuable to
drug companies now because you can
really search for ties between you know
you know what your genes are doing and
what your what your body how your body
is behaving and how did the medical
community come to realize the potential
power of these mutations such as
excessive resilience to pain or
excessive bone formation to treat
opposite conditions like osteoporosis I
what was the aha moment yeah so normally
in the past when Pharma was trying to
understand what our genes did they'd
have to look in mice so you would like
create a knockout mice say you knock out
a gene a specific gene and Masson you
say oh you know what does that do in the
mouse but mice are not humans they're
they're really different so they're not
always the best proxy but you can't
really do this to humans you can't grab
humans off the street and say I'm gonna
knock out one of your genes and see what
happens to you and so the aha moment
here is really when you find someone
like Stephen Peet the guy I interviewed
who doesn't feel pain he's like one of
the drug makers described them as
nature's experiments and being able to
find people like this tells you a lot
about the human body and how other
normal humans like you and I might
behave if we can mimic these conditions
that's certainly very valuable but
what's in it for Steven peat does he get
paid to offer his science up for his
body up for science says is the drug
company looking for a cure for him so
that is one of the ironic realizations I
had when I was working on this story is
that they're people like Steven peat who
are extremely rare there may be a few
dozen people in the world who don't feel
pain
but it really doesn't make sense for
drug makers to be making drugs for this
population just because it's you know
there's not a really a big market for
them so talking to Steven he he said to
me he's willing to take part in research
studies because he wants to further our
understanding of pain as a whole and he
does realize that there is a need for
good new painkillers for the you know
for the masses like you and me but for
now nobody's working on anything to help
him all right bloom rats Carol and Trent
thank you so much fascinating article
once again in this week's edition of
Bloomberg Businessweek carolyn chen
joining us from san francisco